- I feel like there's a tongue
draped over my hand right now.
(upbeat music)
- I've never tried uni before.
- I love sushi, I've never had that.
- My only experience with sea urchins is
Finding Nemo and Freddi the fish.
- My dad loves sushi, and he says that
sea urchin is the worst
thing he's ever eaten.
(upbeat music)
- It's not what I imagined.
- Oh, oh!
- It looks like a tongue.
- It looks like a brain.
- It feels like a slug.
- It's just like, dripping.
- Okay, always wanted to
try it, I'm gonna do it.
- Some sand in there.
- It's actually not that bad (laughs)
- What was that?
- What's the big deal about it?
It was fine.
- It tastes like a combination between
the ocean and shoe leather.
- That intense sea taste
made my stomach turn.
- I can feel it going down my esophagus.
- The texture was like if a
toddler sh(bleep) himself.
- I think it has that kind
of muddy texture to it,
but the flavor is very mild.
- I'm very cheap, so I don't
know if I would pay for this,
but it's good enough to eat
if someone bought it for me.
- Once you get past the diarrhea color
and tongue texture, it's not bad at all.
(upbeat music)
- I always eat animals and then
I feel sorry for them afterwards.
I don't know why.
This always happens to me.